so so they're gonna so a cousin sal
jimmy's cousin is gonna say mike you do
this word and then all you do is
say this and you wait and they they
might ask you what's the origin if they
ask you that you can say this or you can
say it's something that you want to say
if you if you want to make something up
you can say that too
um so that's that's word number one
here's here's another word
destination somebody's name
part of speech a word does it a word
that is weird
used in a sentence it's easier to punch
someone than the spelled i school and
the [ __ ]
let me get a better one from off this
machine
you're great
coincidental
yes
perfect you know
[Music]
sasquatch
some words you can't even spell them you
just know what they are
yes
used in a sentence i would like to fight
the
word infected
the sector to urgent somewhere stupid
definition having a container by
sections
perfectitude yeah
okay
origin doctors
definition a word that begins with an a
part of the speech i think so used in a
sentence after a fight you will
you will need an
anesthesiologist the theology
[Music]
[Music]